oh I really wanted to finish this series
so here's to finishing this series
basically after this um this is the last
episode of Project X and it's really
just gonna be five minutes of time-lapse
and then I'll do a quote-unquote small
and we're supposed to be a small
overview but then actually turn out to
be way more than ten minutes but yeah an
overview of the park
and see what I've got so far and then
I'll probably just start start
complaining about the park and throw my
criticism out there but yeah this is the
last episode which means that I won't be
anything any I won't be adding anything
else but the station of this ride and
just finishing the park in general some
finishing touches here in there that's
really about it and not much more
interesting is really happening a lot of
interesting stuff is actually happening
in the game itself though I don't think
I've talked about the pre-alpha six for
those who don't know pre-alpha six came
out and the game is a lot better overall
and while some elements of the game I
really like so far there is finally a
new palette changes so you can now save
your colors in the game but not only
that you can actually save color schemes
as well and with one click of a button
actually recolor an entire color to a
previously chosen color scheme and
things like that actually really help
the user friendliness of making stuff in
this game there's also a new inverted
coaster which it's a bnm inverted
coaster so that's definitely something I
want to mess around with in with the
future and there's some new interesting
custom scenery as well I just saw me
place that fence over there beautiful
life and he recently came out with a new
path set which achillea has fences but
also curved path covers which is very
helpful but all those things I feel will
be really great for starting a new park
so at the moment I am really looking
forward to start a new park and just
sort of wanted to get this park out of
the way especially with how many new
things have come out since I started
doing this park and how much better the
stuff is that you can make with it
really and so I'm not going to really do
too much with the new customs entry in
this part
I'll just sort of leave it as it is I
have probably said what I wanted to say
in the live part so I won't see it again
I won't say it again but by the time
that this is done this Park is a little
bit outdated I feel and I really wanted
to try some new stuff even though I have
learned a lot of good stuff from this
park I do feel it's time to move on over
here and I do also have to say and this
station is not really too special I
decided that I would keep something more
generic and as one of the biggest
advices to myself for in the next park
make sure that I actually divide the
area into different types of themes and
actually choose themes depending on how
well I can actually tackle the theme
because in hindsight when it comes to
trying the entire Alpine theme it just
doesn't really work in this game and
there's not really any good custom
scenery for it yet or scenery in general
so for the next one I do actually want
to try some concept stuff first it might
take a while before I actually get
started on the new Park in park texts
but I'm far from done in poetics I just
want to kind of improve some stuff and
see what I can do to step up my game
from the next park because that is
pretty much what I wouldn't do with this
and so for this station this also meant
that I wanted to move away from my
attempt at creating Alpine things and
this station is really much more generic
even though it still packs that wooden
look with the brown posts and the brown
roof and all those things and still uses
many of the elements which I've used up
to this point in the park it really
already emits some more modern and
polished look I think and it's more of a
style that I want to go for in the next
park and one of my major things that I
also want to improve on in the next park
is actually the overall planning of the
layouts of the park but also the
individual park sections I think that is
something that I want to take with me as
a constructive point of criticism for
the next park to work on foliage I do
kind of like so far pretty happy about
that
and that's really about it oh yeah one
of the other things was though that the
last rides in this park I all forgot the
name so they are pretty much nameless
which is a bit of a shame as well next
time I do probably want to also go a
little bit more into detail with the
entire park and you know the names that
I choose for things and the overall
theme and give rise their own story
perhaps get into things a little bit
deeper and not just try things out and
practice with stuff but actually put
some real serious effort into the park
into creating what I think is my dream
park but at this point you probably
think that I've talked about the next
park enough and talked [ __ ] about this
bike enough to I do kind of like it
in hindsight and especially this coaster
I kind of like even though it packs a
very very Six Flags ish Aero mega looper
look to it hey I'm kind of glad with it
and I really just wanted to finish this
off with a couple of rocks and some
ferns just scattered about everywhere to
add a little bit more detail to the
foliage and at least keep the foliage
tense around here that's really about it
so you know this sounds a bit weird but
this is recorded after I actually
recorded the real-time footage so you
when you're hearing me now this is the
last you'll technically hear from me in
this series so even at this point I
think I want to say thanks for watching
and to the next book alright so this is
how the park looks in its finished state
and I promised that I would make a small
overview at the end of this series so
here it goes even though as a there's
quite a number of things that I kind of
annoy me about this park and there's a
huge amount of things that I wouldn't
improve on and kind of want to take and
speak back to them to the next bike
there's just also some sort of charm to
the park I suppose and it's my first
Pike in the game which I'm sort of happy
about the way it turned out in the end
what are the things that kind of don't
like about it though is the fact that I
like the Main Street
theme-wise that poke it's just not very
it's there's no real sense of continuity
within the pike even though it is of
course a punk that's supposed to be
built over the years and not really any
of the really large parks like Disney
it's it's still not really too great
when it comes to actually being like one
Pike and the layout is something which
I'm not too happy about it's a bit
rectangular and might wanna also do more
with that at some later stages I do like
the Main Street though it's it's almost
a theme which I wish I would take a
little bit more throughout the rest of
this park but I should definitely get
back to the Alpine theme at some point
in the future when there's actually some
custom scenery that allows you to build
some more Alpine like buildings because
in the end it's it's barely anything
like it sort of resembles it but that
isn't quite close enough I think but
moving on the first area or at least the
first thing that I built over here I
think was the enterprise following this
little coaster but I'm not sure which
came first actually but yeah it's this
was like the first sort of area in the
park of course I wanted to start out
with some of the more mellow rides like
a carousel had chair swing and an
enterprise because whatever I feel like
an enterprise could also work and a
teacups of course which is very hidden
but I'm pretty sure Alma I also promised
that I would do some POVs of the rise as
well so here it goes and I'm looking to
speed up the lift so a little bit it
does have a really really slow lift so
in this game like a bit too slow I would
say but yeah this is the little junior
coaster which I think was actually my
first coaster built in the game or at
least first fully quote-unquote themed
coaster and that is which is just sort
of kind of helixes around the forest and
is more of a family ride than anything I
think this could just still counts as a
junior coaster it's this type of coaster
I believe was actually more or less
conceived to be a
zero type jr. Costa which just goes
around in a figure 8 loop and this this
one is a lot larger than it probably
should be considering the coaster type
but I'm still quite happy with it
especially how it like goes over the
little pond over here I do still have to
say riding the rides themselves really
sort of breaks the entire I don't know
for some reason for me it breaks the
immersion of the game since it really
has that sort of fantasy aesthetic
appeal to it much like the earlier ICT
games and entering a POV mode makes you
realise how low res and while computer
model everything is but um I think I
might want to move on so they wouldn't
coaster now it's perfect timing for it
this has to be my first my AB my whoa
this has to be my favorite roller
coaster in the park actually and I'm
still really happy with how this layout
actually came out in the end I think it
looks pretty good it actually has a
pretty good speed throughout the ride
itself too
you sort of have that view of the
coaster from the other side of the lake
which I like and it's also really smooth
like this to me really proved how good
this coaster editor's for certain
coaster types you would not be able to
build such a rollercoaster ii associate
roller coaster in roller coaster country
especially with the curves and the much
larger hill so that you can make in the
game make making roller coaster Coons
have make making wooden roller coasters
I don't know why I can't talk anymore so
much better in this game and it's not
just one of my favourite coasters and my
favourite coaster that I've built so far
we also kind of like the location it's
realistic but you actually still get a
nice view of it over the lake and then
there's the chair swing which is just
sort of there the same goes for these
two rides I think this one's called
Riptide oh no it's called a wipeout here
pretty sure this is called a Riptide and
roller coaster can three and the
observation none of this is actually
working by the way I should probably
open my park even though it doesn't
really matter since guests don't have a
good ayaats i am might want to open it
we're wait a second send guests home
that's why it's unclick and that over
here is sort of like a separate area I'm
not entirely sure what I would call the
area but it's the more wooden stuff area
with the mountain of course and the log
flume the log flume which I don't think
having a POV of this thing is too
interesting hell I don't even know how
you can actually move two different cars
since it always goes to the first car I
think there was a way but I completely
forgot yeah so that's that I suppose not
that there's too much to see in the log
flume really it's only got one major
drop which drops down over the lake over
here and I do like the way it interacts
with the suspended coaster but god it's
such a ripoff of ninja from Six Flags
and it's almost painful this thing needs
to test by the way I won actually
divided and then over here is like the
little restaurant and I think this area
over here is my favorite area of the
park it's the one area why I truly feel
like it's it's finished and it's got a
really charming look to it especially
the pirate ship is probably my favourite
flat ride but yeah this thing needs to
let's get in there make that bit faster
too and so oh that's actually really
cool to look at the idea is that you
really get this interplay between the
suspended coaster and the log flume but
you've seen that before only issue here
is that the tunnels are extremely
glitchy you are not supposed to use
those tunnels and the POV mod at the
same time and now it swings like crazy
over here I was by the way on purpose
and that's where all the s bands were
for in the end but young quite happy
about the way this thing looks also has
a decent speed and swings quite well
like the trick is to always make a curve
as soon as it swings into the different
direction that the curve is going which
happens most of the time for this ride
almost everywhere which I'm quite happy
about its use the station that is a bit
of a pain for me I'm really not happy
about it it's really just random things
that's one of my main issues that I'm
going to improve on in the next park at
least blend out the station's better and
have them in a different place
considering the rest of the paths and
just make them a lot better in general
and also mention that they should be
raised so much that's one of the issues
because the coaster tracks in some of
these stations were so damn high
I'd have to raise the station walls as
well and get very elongated stations
because of that and then over here is
the thrill zone not too much to say sort
of just backed all the thrill rides
together in a mouse we're all the sort
of sense over here with the drop tower
and the top spin you call that alright
you do call that a top spin and there's
also the G lock which is this thing is a
monstrosity really like as soon as it
runs I don't know if you can test for a
second but this is probably the one
right that I would probably never ride
in this bike oh yeah there it goes it
just looks very menacing I do love that
thing though this area in general I'm
quite happy about and then there's of
course the lost arrow coaster which this
is actually more or less the type of
station that I would want to move
towards even though I have that transfer
track over here pretty much out of
necessity because I would normally I
would normally want to have my transfer
track much closer to the station best
case scenario is actually a building
that's nearly attached to the station or
having your transfer track within the
same building as the station but since
it's so far from the station I figured I
would put a small roof over it but then
it just looked like a container books
and nothing really good came out of that
so I'm just leaving the station as it is
right now but this is more or less more
of the thing that I would like to go
with though I also have to say having
the new color palettes did help out a
lot while making this station it's far
from perfect
but it's it's so helpful to be able to
keep your colors and instantly get the
same color scheme just by clicking on
something
yeah this is the nameless hero coaster I
think I'll just test it like this and
get on it if it's actually gonna there
we go and yeah this is accidentally way
too much of a ripoff of the Viper oh
well not much now I can do about it I
suppose
I originally wanted to have a color
scheme more reminiscent of vortex but
with the way that colors work in that in
this game I just couldn't really do it
since you can't recolor the rails
separately but instead you recolor the
ties which is kind of painful and yeah
that's pretty much why I went with fiery
standard blue track and white supports
color scheme in this case I mean I do
like the ride in the end but it's very
similar to already existing coasters now
there was something else I wanted to say
about this but I completely forgot what
it was oh yeah that this actually the
track is not like Aero coasters at all
it's very much a Morgan coaster track
actually I would say hell you could
probably use this coaster track to make
a JP Morgan hyper light I mean mega
lights I think that's what they call
them yeah that's about it over there
actually like how that workman is using
the special paths for stuff but yeah
that's the entire park I actually have
no name for the park which is quite
funny next time that I'll be making a
park I'll come up with the name
beforehand and actually name the series
after that because that's a bit of a
better planning and overall plan it a
little better because truth be told in
retrospect this park it was a lot of fun
to build it and I've actually had a lot
of fun playing the game so far but it's
really more of a test park and first
kind of thing to get the hang of it and
it should help a lot with my next park
and I'll definitely take a lot of
feedback from this Pike do the next one
but God I really want to start building
a next bike and I'm just so done with
this park not in a really bad sense but
just in a sense that I'm gonna start
again and getting more themed thing
going but yeah that's it for this series
so thank you guys for watching and I'll
possibly see you guys in the future